[Música]
hola les damos la bienvenida a enlace
centroamérica de nicaragua desde costa
rica el 7 de noviembre están previstas
las elecciones generales pero la
oposición en ese país organismos locales
e internacionales países del continente
y de la unión europea sostienen que
estos comicios no serán democráticos
libres competitivos justos ni
transparentes el gobierno del presidente
daniel ortega comenzó este año electoral
con una cacería de sus posibles
contrincantes en la contienda los
opositores detenidos ya pasan los 30
ortega se enfila a seguir manteniendo el
poder absoluto sobre nicaragua
aspirantes presidenciales dirigentes
opositores defensores de derechos
humanos empresarios y periodistas han
sido encarcelados desde finales de mayo
ante una elección sin competencia
política ya que fue eliminado el único
partido inscrito que aglutinaba a parte
importante de la oposición las
autoridades aseguran que los detenidos
han cometido delitos como lavado de
dinero o conspiración contra la
integridad nacional pero los familiares
de los detenidos la comunidad
internacional organismos de derechos
humanos locales e internacionales
aseguran que estos son presos políticos
todos han sido formalmente acusados y
enfrentan juicios señalados como
irregulares por sus defensores
la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos reporta que además de los
últimos detenidos hay 125 presos por
razones políticas en las cárceles en su
mayoría son personas que se manifestaron
contra el presidente ortega en las
masivas protestas que fueron reprimidas
en 2018 dejando un saldo de 300 muertes
miles de heridos y miles de personas
detenidas arbitrariamente la cdh también
ha señalado que desde entonces el
gobierno de nicaragua viola las
libertades civiles y los derechos
humanos de manera sistemática
conversamos con anna maría chamorro
hermana de uno de los aspirantes
presidenciales
encarcelados juan sebastián chamorro
sobre los procesos de los detenidos
entonces ya sabemos que el juicio va a
continuar con una prueba falsa las
pruebas que no tienen ningún mérito y
eso va a continuar pues entonces sí
claro o sea mi hermano es inocente
entonces nosotros como familia él tiene
que estar libre pero las circunstancias
son otras mi hermano siempre ha amado a
nicaragua y quiere lo mejor para
nicaragua entonces no tiene sentido las
acusaciones como ninguna de las
acusaciones que le están haciendo a los
30 detenidos
está en el chipote y los 140 presos
políticos que están en las casas
nicaragua vive su peor crisis económica
de los últimos 30 años la represión
desde 2018 la incertidumbre política
elevada ha sumado a la pandemia de kobe
19 ha profundizado la problemática
económica del país
bajo el mando del sandinismo nicaragua
se mantiene como uno de los países menos
desarrollados del continente de acuerdo
al banco mundial la pobreza en 2020 se
contabilizaba en 14.7 por ciento datos
de economistas nicaragüenses señalan que
desde 2018 se perdieron unos 200 mil
puestos de trabajo en el sector formal
debido a la inestabilidad política que
provocó el cierre de empresas por otra
parte según las cifras oficiales del
instituto nacional de información de
desarrollo a inicios de este año la tasa
de desempleo abierto se ubicó en 4.9 por
ciento y el 44.6 por ciento de la
población ocupada se encuentra en el
subempleo la agencia de las naciones
unidas para los refugiados acnur señala
que desde 2018 la crisis económica y la
persecución política han provocado el
desplazamiento de más de 100.000
personas
daniel ortega comandante guerrillero de
la revolución sandinista que derrocó a
la dictadura de somoza en 1979
del país por cuatro mandatos el primero
en la década de 1980 y los últimos tres
a partir de 2007 junto a su esposa
rosario murillo y se presidenta desde
en su proyecto de perpetuación en el
poder ortega y murillo han instaurado un
estado policial de facto que prohíbe
cualquier manifestación de disidencia
han censurado confiscado y cerrado
medios de comunicación y creado leyes
consideradas represivas
países e instituciones extranjeras que
abogan por un diálogo en nicaragua creen
que la pareja presidencial se encamina a
una reelección que carecerá de
legitimidad por el hecho de encarcelar a
sus adversarios y legitimidad que no
preocupa al mandatario nicaragüense
quien cuenta con el apoyo de los poderes
del estado la policía y militares para
gobernar por un nuevo periodo la
oposición en prisión y desde el exilio
insiste en que unas elecciones
verdaderamente democráticas libres
transparentes y observadas son la
solución a este conflicto pero pareciera
que no habrá punto de consenso
ortega y murillo por ahora están
ocupados de llegar a una contienda sin
oponentes
hasta aquí con este enlace centroamérica
de nicaragua desde costa rica gracias
por habernos acompañado para ver
nuestros programas síganos en france 24
y france 24 puntocom